mr. Benkelman thank you very much for
joining us on Bloomberg Television we've
got a reactive car here light as a
feather pretty quick tell us about it
hey this is the new Aventador and p750
dish for super veloce super veloce
stands for super fast we were
concentrating on three items
power-to-weight ratio so increasing
horsepower from 700 to 750 reducing the
weight to have a perfect power-to-weight
ratio we improved aerodynamics so the
downfall is increased by a hundred and
seventy percent thanks to a new front
rear diffuser in the big wing and then
the drivability so make the drivability
better by pushrod suspensions with magna
ride and lamborghini dynamic theory not
on sale yet in the US what do they sell
for in Europe then it's around about
twenty percent up from the coop yeah so
where would in the 320,000 urea [ __ ]
yeah well Tom keen my host he could buy
two at that price ok he's a good boy and
yeah we will start say it's all over the
world from some of this year now I think
Lamborghini I think low to the ground
and yet there's some talk you've had a
concept car about an SUV there's all
this SUV talking Geneva here what do you
what's your thought I know the board
hasn't decide yet what's your thought on
raising this one up and making it a
crossover an SUV you know that
Lamborghini beside the history of super
sports cars we made GT cars we made two
plus tools and we also made in back in
time and SUV so it fits to the brand
it's a growing segment it's very
distributed all over the world it has a
whole lot of emotion for four door car
and so we think that this would be a
perfect fit give us give us a little bit
in terms of market expectations for the
following 2015 China's slowdown Russia
slow down where are you optimistic I'm
optimistic for the US I'm optimistic for
some European markets for the Middle
East still
asia-pacific is an important market what
we have rose in taxation we have a
slowdown in China like you said but all
in all I think that we are going to
increase the number of sales in
comparison to 14 and at a time is that
true in Russia as well will you sell
more Lamborghinis in Russia than Russia
is a very small market when it comes to
super sports cars yeah it's wrong to
compare the total market with the super
sports car so there's a very small
market so we are not so affected like
other manufacturers on the fact that
they just slow down her Ken sales have
you been they've been great so far and
with the older bank we have now so the
priests old car we are almost covering
the entire year 2050 you're in a
position they sort of adjudicate this
claim you know the CDN is so much weaker
now some of the Japanese companies have
an advantage you're here with the weaker
currency but not that much weaker do the
Japanese auto companies have a bit of an
unfair advantage right now I you know I
advantages come and go and I think that
this the ups and downs are part of our
business otherwise we would move
production every second minute and I
think the more we have a unification of
the free market the better so also for
the for the currencies that we will see
where this is going to end we are happy
at this stage and we always there would
be further grow spot okay well thank you
very much I appreciate